we talk about core formats and that's a
term that's new for me
so what should a writer know about
creating story for each one and I
understand in your book you talk about
the one-hour drama or dramedy 30-minute
single-camera sitcom 30-minute
multi-camera sitcom a 30-minute drama
dihybrid or the web series which is
credibly popular well first things first
write something that you would want to
watch write a format that you love that
you would want to watch so if you prefer
one-hour dramas like Breaking Bad or
madman or something like that then write
one of those ideally you would know
those formats so if you love Breaking
Bad Mad Men The Good Wife then you would
probably know a little bit more about
that format you've just internalized a
little bit more about that format and
ideally you want to map out or outline
out several episodes of your favorite
shows before you tackle that first pilot
so you understand the structure a little
bit more and you're not just writing
freeform especially if you're coming
from features because you really need to
understand the TV structure so write
what you know and love and would watch
the 30-minute drama d-10 they tend to
have more of a cultural viewpoint
there's more diversity in the 30-minute
drama tease and they're more they're set
in a more specific world definitely than
definitely more than like a multi-camera
sitcom like a Big Bang Theory for
example it's more of a subculture it's
more of a micro culture and I guess
you'd say a personal viewpoint but the
more personal you can get the more
specific you can get that applies to any
format what do you see many people
venturing into these days like the
webseries says which has been the most
popular 2016-2017 well there are more
one-hour scripted dramas than other
formats actually out there in the
marketplace like on cable you know on on
your TV or on a streaming service like
Amazon or Netflix so they're more of the
but I really think you should write what
you want to watch so it's really up to
you there may be more one hours being
made than any other format but in my
opinion the most interesting and unique
and experimental form today is the 30
minute single camera show whether it's
single camera sitcom or single camera
drama dihybrid there just is more going
on there there's more unique creator
driven material than ever in that format
and I would like to think that networks
are more open to it and streaming
services are more open to it because it
is cheaper to create to produce a 30
minute show than a 1-hour scripted show
certainly like a one hour action show or
one hour period piece those are going to
be really expensive so it's cheaper and
some of them come from web series
something like Issa Rae doing insecure
started as a web series difficult people
was a web series so it's easier to get
in the door with an established
30-minute series
you
formats because you've
snap them out there's a male the poster
yeah rain sleet or snow